The Barter System.
Billy is a lumberjack and Mary is an egg farmer.
After chopping down many trees, Billy soon has more wood than he needs.
Similarly, Mary soon has more chickens and more eggs than she can eat.
That means they have a surplus.
Billy, after chopping down all of the trees, is now very hungry...
...and would very much like some food.
And Mary would like some firewood so she can cook her food.
And thus, a trade will develop between Billy and Mary.
Given enough time, an exchange rate will also develop:...
...say, one egg for one medium-sized log.
But these rates could change.
If some of the chickens died, Mary might demand more logs per egg....
...since she will have less eggs now to trade.
If there were a forest fire, the lumberjack might want more eggs...
...in exchange for his wood.